I've overcome the worst wave, so I
'm fine.As a reward, I made Raphtalia's former home,
Rorona Village, my territory.Reconstruction
progresses and new friends are added, and things are going smoothly.Even in the
next wave, the people I met in this world will
definitely fall.
Be careful
Hiryoko-
sama Tycole Eh, I'm trying to save my attention around the pit of my plexus
Isn't this like this?
I don't quite understand when that time comes
Ah Heart 02-chan Boo Adult Sanma
You seem to be working hard, Kiel, it's obvious
Baba Don't spoil Lisha too much
This guy's base stats are extremely low for his level
.
It's true that the effects of the costume can't be taken
lightly. Hey,
I'm just relying on it.  It
's true,
why did you stretch out?
Well, it
's less than a week until the next wave.It's
just not enough time to make the
weaker one a full-fledged
master.  But if it's swordsmanship, it's not just about the graveyard.
Are these guys
a kind of dimensional monsters
?  Music]
Thank you, Mr.
Earl,
Mr. Lesha, at the party that Mr. Lesha was
at.  In the middle of the demons, I
also encountered everyone who was creepy
Do
you know something, dear?
[Music] It
was something
I'd never seen before It didn't even feel like a dimensional monster that came out
of something.
According to reports, the
legendary monster Hyoga, which bears its name, was
resurrected after returning home from Kurosuzu.
Things are cut due to the resurrection of things as a brake
Unprecedented disaster, is
n't it like a wave?
I was summoned to the world,
so I
don't
have time to worry about effects Right Naofumi
[Music]
What did you have?  Oh
, I'm sorry,
but it's been a long time
since
then
.
]
Aka
nan ps 3 I'm also a painting summoner God ah ah ah I can't do it
for you No matter how much Naoshimura trains me, it's useless
I
'm stuck
[music]
May-sama wonders why barbie Karatsu
Kaname  I think it was
to keep me away from the dangerous ship
.
And
I guess I chose them to ask them
to subjugate that rake.
No, if I were to use an
example, would you accept Hirai
?
It is a country located in the far east where it is approaching that auto while causing 100 casualties.
It's only a matter of time before we reach Melromark here.If that happens,
we can expect damage to the Hero of the Shield-sama's territory.As
usual, you
're a predator.Meltia, are you doing well?
Place
I was thinking that I was going to build a bridge between people, but this commotion happened just as I was about to leave this place to me and say hello to my mother
.
It
seems like it
's happened Well, it's for the sake of Aizu's feelings, and for the sake of the territory.
That's also
something I'm curious about
.
920 It's a hot topic
Merlot There's even talk of dispatching a squadron
to form an alliance with other countries
.
Come in, the queen with a stylish head has a lot of blood
Hey,
what about this,
Mr. E, who has a
far door
?  It's better than just having it
Ga
Excuse me
[music]
Ah 4 a It
's so hard Ah Mr. Zhengzhou
I have a good idea
Oh oh oh
oh It
's
okay I'm not scared
Wow
[music] Hey
you
Risa-san, who's like a vertical hot water tea, why don't you try becoming a tray for a moment
?
Then you'll soon become stronger than the parking lot of the hero of the bow
Take
off your clothes and show your chest
Craft 4 a
I
'm not going to force anyone to become my slave
anymore Sorry
Char-san
If you think you can become like
me  If you think about it, it's different,
but Raphtalia is the only one who likes and likes it
.
Hey, Fumi-san,
please make it a tray for the two heroes
[music]
me
Then
[music]
Bach
sister me yes
Now you're a slave to the vertical doctor
Furan is timid at all.
I'm good at this kind of thing.Is
it so much that you want the 5 family to recognize that's
why I'm being trained by Mr. Naofumi?
I'm
going
to leave for the cold country first thing tomorrow morning
Yes, I'm hungry
20 minutes
carmeparmeme
me
uuuuuuuu
[music] do annoying [music]
nmasu Naofumi-sama
The people just now
must have escaped from the Reiki country
.
There's Mr. Kase, right now.
I can hear
something, but that ahoge is an antenna or something
I told the heroes of the shield that were lined up, that's
the choice I told them about.
What does it have to do with the cold
?  Are you going to be killed by the Queen of Philo Rial, or are you
still attached to
the hilt?  It's empty
It's said that even
the heroes of the municipal government were called in
. You're old, and you challenge the cold with
Yushagi-san.  It's a
story about what to do
with the waves.The guys summoned by Kurumadama are all overwhelmed by the
bar.I remember it's October.
I
don't know if he understands, but ask if
any one of the heroes who are summoned now has
died
[
MUSIC: It seems that the head is in. Don't
worry for the time being.
Following me, our company sent 10
people into town me
[music]
can
nitame ni I
can't see
[music] Olegar for
those who were late to escape
[music]
[laughter]
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
it's okay.
Please kill me
[music]
rar
Hosonoha Tokyu store also recruits mothers and
caregivers for viruses
[music]
delan